Would you like to rule? Do you see problems in your country and know how to fix it?
Because you had the power to do this.
Well, you've come to the right place.
But before we begin this lecture on political power, ask yourself why rulers do not look at things as clear as you ...
... on the contrary, behave in a manner, selfish, self-conscious and short-term?
Are they stupid ... the most powerful people in the world?
Or is it something else?
The throne seems omnipotent from afar, but it is not as it seems.
Take the throne to act, and the throne acts upon you.
Accept this or go back now before discussing the rules for the ruler.
* gloomy music *
As bright as the rays of any sunny king: No one rules alone.
A king can not build a street alone, can not enforce the law alone and can not protect the state alone.
The power of a king is not to act, but to do others act on his behalf, using the treasure in his ark.
The king needs an army and someone to run.
Treasure and someone to collect.
Law and Someone to Ensure Its Implementation.
Individuals needing to do these things are the keys to power.
All the changes you want to do are just thoughts in your head if the keys do not apply your commands.
In a dictatorship, where power is right, the number of power cords is small, ...
... maybe just a dozen generals, bureaucrats and regional leaders.
Move them to your side and the power to rule is yours, but ...
... never forget: burn them and they will replace you.
Every country lies in a spectator ranging from those in which the ruler is called for only a few key supporters, in those who need more ...
... this foundation of power is why states are different.
But many keys or less, the rules are the same:
First, take the key supporters on your side.
With them, you have the power to act; you have everything. Without them, you have nothing.
Now to keep these keys of power, the second rule is:
Check the treasure
You need to make sure that all the treasury is gathered and distributed to you - for all the effort you have made
- and keys to save your position
This is your job as a ruler: to discover the best way to gather and distribute resources,
... so as not to rupture the bed of letters on which the thrust is supported.
Now you, a loving aspiring dictator, may have the desire to help the people, ...
... but your treasury control is one that draws rivals, so you have to keep the keys faithful.
But there is only a limited amount of treasure in your arena, a limited amount of treasury that your kingdom produces.
So be careful: every small amount you spend for the people is a treasure not spent on loyalty.
So, making the right genes, spurring the wealth of a state to the citizens of the state, ...
... you are your rivals a tool to take power.
The treasure trove in the streets, in universities and hospitals, is a treasure that a rival could promise the key supporters if they would turn away.
The loving dictators can spend their share on the citizens, but the keys need to get their rewards ...
because * even if * you have gathered faithful and angelic supporters, they have the same problem, just one level below ...
Being a power key is in itself a power position.
And they are guarded by rivals from below or from above: so the treasure they take will spend it to preserve their position.
Loyalties and fools can stand by your side in any situation, ...
... but smart supporters will always look at the balance of power, ready to change loyalty if you look like a lost candidate in a mobile alliance network.
In countries where the celsat are packed, so big bonuses ...
... and where violence rules, the most ruthless gathering; and the angels who do good are lost against the devils who do not.
So buy all the loyalty you can, because loyalty to dictatorial organizations of all kinds is all.
For rulers at least.
So, the exposed dictatorship:
A king who needs a royal court to collect the treasure, to keep the courtyard loyal and to continue the treasury collection.
This is the self-supporting core of power, everything beyond it is secondary.
A king with many key supporters has real problems:
not just spending, but also their competitive needs and rivalry are difficult to balance, ...
... the more complicated the social and financial networks between them, the more likely there is a rival to shift a critical mass.
The more supporters of the key have an average king, the shorter his rule.
What brings us to the third rule for the rulers.
Minimize key supporters
If a key in your yard becomes unnecessary and your skills too, you must debit it.
After a successful coup, the new dictator will cleanse some of those who helped him come to power, ...
... as well as cooperating with the support of the previous dictator - which from the outside looks like a terrible idea.
Why to abandon your revolutionary friends?
Are not they a threat to the old dictator's support?
But the keys needed to gain power are not the same as they need to keep it.
To pay someone who was necessary in the past, but futile now is the same as spending money on citizens: treasure worn for irrelevant.
By definition, a dictator taking a coup has promised more treasure to those who take his side.
The size of the ark has not changed, so the treasure should be shared with few.
A dictator who moves the right keys, takes control of the treasury, shortens unnecessary expenses and kills the useless keys, will have a long and successful career.
Seeing the structure to be revealed, you may be excited to start and control a site for your own good and your friends.
... or you may be exhausted, wanting to do well, but seeing the structural difficulties now return to democracy for salvation.
So let's discuss the rulers as representatives.
You can still have great dreams of utopia you want to build, but: no one rules alone.
And never less than in democracy.
Presidents and prime ministers should negotiate with their senates and parliaments and vice versa.
And they all have their key backers to manage.
In a well-designed democracy, power is fragmented among many members and taken not by force, but in words, ...
... Which means you have to convince thousands or millions of citizens, even if you like on the polling day, ...
... at least you like more than the other alternative.
With so many voters and such fragmented power it is impossible to become a dictator ...
..., follow these rules and buy loyalty. Or is it not?
Of course not.
Do not think citizens as individuals with their individual desires but as divided into blocks:
... Older people, homeowners, business owners, or the poor. Blocks you can reward as a group.
Democracies have exceptionally complicated tax codes and laws, not by chance, but as rewards
for the blocks that raise and hold the representatives in power:
agricultural subsidies, for example, have nothing to do with food for which a nation needs ...
... But entirely with the importance of the bloc's agricultural vote.
Countries where farmers' votes do not affect the election, do not have agricultural subsidies.
If a bloc, as a new citizen, can not vote, then there is no need to divert rewards to them.
Even if they are large in number, they are irreversible to gain power.
This is good news for you: a little block to win and anyway, the treasure should come from somewhere ...
If you want long years in the office, the three rule is your friend in a democracy just as much as dictatorship.
You can not eliminate those who do not vote for you, but there are a lot you can do.
Once you are in power, make it easier for your party blocks to vote and make it harder for others.
Create voting systems that reduce the number of blocks you need to win as many rivals as you can ...
... really very useful.
Put the boundaries of the election to predetermine the outcome for you and your friends, ...
... And do the party's default with Byzantine rules to determine which blocks * can * vote.
Combine the above methods for even more pronounced power extension.
When the satisfaction level can not be lower, but the re-rate may not be higher, ...
... you will know that you have achieved.
Now, quite with the opinion of the citizens.
Even in a democracy there are individual supporters with more influence
... who you need on your side because your money, influence, or favors hold you in power.
So you can promise to give it straight to the treasure as a dictator would do ...
... You can create opportunities for their investments, adopt laws they have written, ...
... or allow them to leave the prison freely.
Not a full cart with gold at their door but a contract for their business.
You as a ruler have the way to build, store computers or rebuild buildings.
No one rules alone, ultimately.
Or you can get the moral path, and ignore the big keys.
But you will fight against those who have not done so. Good luck with that.
Corruption is not a kind of crime, in contrast to a power tool, ...
... In democracy and dictatorship, but more on this at another time.
So, please favor, move the key blocks and you will get the power, ...
... to rule with actions that seem contradictory and thick for those who do not understand the game -
to privately support the industry you have denounced publicly, ...
... Or to adopt laws that hurt a block that voted you.
But your job is not to have a stable and understandable policy, ...
... But balance the interests of your power keys, big and small.
That's how you stand on duty.
Now with all this headache to being a representative, you may wonder, ...
Looking at three rules, why can not you avoid all this building blocks and the exchange of favors ...
... and just corrupt the army to take power?
We must finally return: taxes and insurrections.
You need to understand the rule two and how the treasure is collected and used to hold a unified place.
If we put the state tax rates in the graph against the number of key supporters that the ruler needs, ...
... There is a clear relationship. More democracy, lower taxes. \
If you are in a comfortable democracy, you will perceive this, ...
... but your co-citizens who do not earn enough do not pay their income tax and even receive compensation ...
... Taking the * average * tax rate down. In dictatorships, this does not happen.
Dictatorships often abandon indirect taxes in favor of getting wealth straight.
It is common for a dictator to force farmers to sell their products for a bit, ...
... then turn and sell them to the free market,
... keeping the difference as an equivalent to an exceptionally high tax.
So taxes on democracy are low compared to those of dictatorships.
But why do the representatives lower the amount they receive?
Well, tax reduction is a thrill of crowds.
Dictators do not need to please the crowds and so they can get a large percentage of their poor citizens to pay for key supporters.
But representatives in democracy can take a smaller percentage ...
from each to pay their key supporters, ...
... because their educated and free citizens are more productive than the peasants.
For the rulers in a democracy, the more productivity the better.
That is why they build universities, hospitals, roads and guarantee freedom, ...
... Not only by the goodness of their heart, but because it increases the productivity of citizens, ...
... which increases the treasury for their rulers and their key supporters, even if they take a lower percentage.
Democracies are the best place to live that dictatorships, ...
... Not because representatives are better people, ...
... but because * happens that * their needs are compatible with most of the population.
Things that make the citizens more productive make their lives better.
Representatives want everyone productive, so everyone takes the freeways.
The worst dictators are those that match the interests with the smallest share of citizens, ...
... those who have the smallest amount of power keys.
That explains why the worst dictatorships have something in common.
Gold, oil, diamonds or the like.
If the wealth of a nation is mainly exported from the earth: this is a terrible place to live ...
... Because a gold mine can operate with slaves who are dying, and yet produce a lot of wealth.
Oil is more difficult, but fortunately foreign companies can extract and process it without the need for citizen involvement.
With citizens outside of this cycle, they can be ignored, while the ruler is rewarded and the keys to power are kept loyal.
So we live in a world where the best and smart democracies are sustainable, ...
... the worst and richest dictatorships are sustainable and in the middle of a revolutionary valley.
Resource-rich dictators construct roads only from ports to rescues and from their palace at the airport, ...
... and people stay calm not because it is acceptable or that they are afraid, ...
... but because the bitter truth is that: disconnected and hungry illiterates are not revolutionary.
Now an average dictator with no resources should, as mentioned before, need to take a large amount of wealth directly from his poor farmers and factory workers.
So two ways are not enough and he has to maintain some living standards for the citizens.
But keeping the work force somewhat united, somewhat educated and somewhat healthy ...
... makes them more capable of revolting.
Now, understand: the romantic image of the people by attacking the gates and by knocking down the dictator is mostly just a fantasy.
If you have an average dictatorship, people will attack the palace only if the army allows them to take you away ...
... because you have lost control over your keys and are being replaced.
That is why after the "popular revolts" in the average dictatorship, the new ruler is often the same as the oldest, if not the worse.
People did not replace the king, the yard replaced the king by using the people's protest to do so.
The bridges that a loving dictator wants to build to overcome the valley ...
... take the treasure from the keys of power and make the citizens capable of revolting, ...
... often ending with a stricter ruler, loyal to the keys, and less likely to build bridges.
On the other hand, the best democracies are stable not only because the large number of keys ...
... and their competitive desires that make dictatorial revolts almost impossible to organize, ...
... but also because the revolt would destroy the wealth that was intended to be taken.
High productivity of citizens themselves.
Plus: those who would help the future dictator in a democracy know that he plans to get rid of some keyboards when he gets into power.
This is the meaning of a state coup.
So, potential key supporters need to weigh the probability of survival and potential rewards ...
... against the risk of being on the outside of a dictatorship that helped create.
In a stable democracy, this is a terrible gamble:
maybe you will be too rich, ...
... but most likely you will be dead and you will have wiped the lives of everybody you know. Mathematics says no.
Being in the right arm in a coup is meant to have the resources to secure for yourself and your family what the peasants do not have.
Health care, education, quality of life - these are the things that make the race for fierce power.
But in a democracy most have these things, why not risk it?
So, the more a nation's wealth comes from the productive citizens of the nation, ...
... the more power is dispersed, and the more the ruler must preserve the quality of life for those citizens.
The less, the less.
Now if a stable democracy becomes too poor, ...
... or if a source is found that leaves behind the productivity of citizens, ...
... the chances of this game change, and it is possible for a small group to take power.
Because if the present quality of life is terrible, or wealth does not depend on citizens, it is worth risking the coups of the state.
When democracies fall, these are usually the reasons.
Conclusion * Gloomy music *
These rules for rulers explain not only why some people are monstera and others are merciful, ...
... but everything about politics: from war to international aid, political dynasties and corruption.
We can all talk about it all at once.
But for now, you, inspirational ruler, can be tired of the world of politics, ...
... And you decided to avoid it altogether, but you can not do it because the rulers come in many forms.
Yes, kings, presidents and prime ministers, but also deans, mayors and chiefs.
These rules apply to everyone and explain their actions: by CEO of the largest global corporate conglomerate ...
... who has to hold his happy board, chairman of the smallest association of house owners, ...
... who manages votes and expense of membership fee.
You can not avoid the power structures.
You can only turn a blind eye to their understanding, and ...
... if you ever want the change you dream of, there is a rule that you can not ignore.
Without power you can not influence anything.
You may not like these rules, but surely, you better thrust than someone else.
And who knows, maybe you will be different.
* Gloomy piano music, which slowly disappears *
This video and its posterity are mostly based on The Dictator's Handbook by Bruce Bueno de Mesquita and Alistair Smith, ...
... which is simply the best written book on politics.
There are many more details and many more examples that I can hope to show in a series of videos.
Every citizen should read this book, and ...
... if you want to support the channel, you can get a copy of it at Audible.com/Grey~~ which is where I discovered this book many years ago
If you subscribe to the Audible with that URL, you can get a thirty-day free trial, and listen to the book (not in Albanian).
So if you want to understand people's politics, if you want to understand the rules for rulers as applied to everything, ...
... Go to audible.com/grey~~ and download a copy of The Dictator's Handbook.
You will not regret it.
Start 30-day proven free, listen to this book, hear one of the 18,000 other audiobooks
... and other audio audio products that Audible offers.
They are a fantastic service. Audible is the way I pick up and listen to my audiobooks. You too can do the same thing.
Audible.com/grey~~ Thanks for channel support